efectivamente se espera que este
miércoles a partir de las seis de la
tarde el gobernador de Florida anuncie
formalmente su candidatura por el
partido de republicano de Cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 está
previsto que es lo haga a efectivamente
a través de la plataforma de Twitter y
con su fundador El Magnate el más a
pesar de que ni el equipo de ron de
santis ni tampoco es lo más han
confirmado al respecto lo ha dicho la
cadena estadounidense Fox de anunciarse
esta candidatura ron de Santi se
convertiría en el candidato más
conservador del partido republicano y se
vería las caras con su principal
contrincante el expresidente Donald
Trump de hecho en las últimas horas A
poco después de que se anunciara la
posibilidad de que este miércoles antes
anunciar esta candidatura pues varios
grupos de simpatizantes de Don ald Trump
han dicho que no está preparado para
estas elecciones presidenciales
principalmente porque critican que no
tiene un plan económico para hacer
frente a esta situación de crisis
económica que vive el país y porque
también contempla hacer grandes recortes
al seguro social bueno y justamente Qué
impacto tiene este anuncio en la carrera
por la nominación republicana
Sí pues efectivamente drones antes si se
anunciara finalmente como está previsto
este miércoles esa candidatura pues se
convertirían en el candidato más
conservador principalmente porque en las
últimas semanas ha estado aprobando
leyes muy controvertidas Como por
ejemplo la ley del aborto que reduce el
plazo para
abortar de 15 a 6 semanas también la ley
que permite libreporte de armas en
Florida pero la más polémica ha sido la
ley sb1718 que de alguna manera
criminaliza la migración irregular con
penas de hasta 15 años de prisión a
quienes transporten inmigrantes
indocumentados a Florida o también
multas de hasta 1000 dólares a las
empresas que contraten a indocumentados
pero como les digo este la candidatura
de dron de santis se verá verá esa pugna
Donald Trump pero también con otros
candidatos como Niki Halley la
exgobernadora de Carolina del Sur que
también se ha pronunciado sobre esta
posible candidatura de rondes antes
diciendo que él tiene la incapacidad de
interactuar con los votantes y también
hay otros candidatos que ya han
oficializado su candidatura por el
partido republicano de Cara a las
elecciones de 2024 Como por ejemplo Team
Scott que es el primer senador en negro
en más de un siglo en el senado de
Estados Unidos O también
que fue dos veces gobernador de Arkansas
y ha sido uno de los pocos críticos uno
de los pocos candidatos que han sido
críticos con Donald Trump